in june of 2014 a
single barrel of oil cost 114
today the price is just 50 this drop is
far beyond the usual fluctuations of
price of this raw material and beyond
the predictions of pessimistic defenders
of the peak oil theory the theory that
we are about to have a severe shortage
because petroleum is
always running out the estimated peak
would occur about 1995 and
we're going to decline the truth is that
there are many different factors that
suggest that the price of petroleum is
going to remain
low for quite some time this is mainly
due to two reasons
the first is the constant improvement of
energy efficiency
meaning that we have a lesser need for
energy this is logical when you think
that the group of oecd countries that's
the world's wealthiest countries are
using the same amount of primary energy
as they used in the year 2000 but
they are producing 30 percent more the
us is the biggest market with 40
000 plug-in cars purchased there in the
first six months of this year a second
reason is
innovation and technological development
a field of expertise that is inherent to
human evolution this is a development
that has occurred on two fronts both
fossil fuels as well as renewable
energies the best example of this
might be fracking this is a technology
that has provided the world with a large
amount of oil as well as natural gas
in fact this technology alone has led to
the u.s doubling its oil production and
currently that country is producing more
oil than it has since the 1970s
now on the other hand the ecological
impact of fracking is a highly
controversial topic but that's something
we're going to address in a later video
now the reduced price of oil has been an
incredible setback for persian gulf
countries where 85
of their revenue relies on this resource
up until now this has allowed for the
payment of all kinds of bills
citizens have got used to high levels of
subsidies and allowances
while also getting used to not having to
pay any taxes oil has subsidized
everything water electricity fuel
low interest loans our citizens have
also got used to the idea that they have
a right to a well-paid civil service job
[Music]
furthermore countries in the persian
gulf have got used to spending an
enormous amount of money on
guns in fact they have spent so much
money on weaponry that saudi arabia now
spends more on its military
than russia this makes it the country
with the third
largest military budget globally
[Music]
further we all know that oil money has
paid for pro-islamic campaigns all
around the world
however these pre-existing policies have
become completely unsustainable due to
the drop
in the price of oil in fact in 2015
alone
oil-producing countries lost 360
billion dollars in oil revenues
and this is all because of the hard drop
in the price of oil
now don't get me wrong they do still get
an enormous amount of money
from oil saudi arabia for example gets
around 5
500 per capita from its black
gold but despite this still significant
amount of income they are unable to
maintain all of the subsidies that they
have established because of this
changing scenario all countries in the
persian gulf are announcing ambitious
plans to diversify their economies
this will allow them to get some
distance from their economies completely
relying on oil
they are looking to follow dubai's
example which has been one of the only
countries to successfully transition
away from a totally oil-based economy in
the last 40 years
[Music]
because of this diversification away
from oil the emirates is becoming a
world leader in terms of tourism
trade and logistics
tens of billions of dollars are being
invested into qatar
with the hope that it will become an
economy of knowledge
they proudly show off their education
city development
a huge educational complex where some of
the most prestigious schools in the
world can be found
there are also notable researchers
working there with budgets that seem
almost infinite however the most
archetypical case is the one we find in
saudi arabia one of the world's most
suffocating and terrifying countries
human rights in saudi arabia are nothing
more than
an illusion women are forced to marry
underage and they can't even drive
further dozens of executions occur every
year and torture is quite routine
blasphemy homosexual acts treason and
murder are punishable
by death through beheading in saudi
arabia and islamic state
further the country has even banned
theaters and nightclubs
in saudi arabia religion and
fundamentalism are more important than
anything else
but their economic crisis cannot be
escaped and today they are facing a very
complex
situation in 2015 the deficit was 15
of the gdp and this continued into 2016.
this is threatening to swallow up all of
the money that they saved during the
black
gold years further unemployment is
becoming a major concern and this
is no more true than among young people
the unemployment rate is currently
sitting for young people at around
40 percent this is why in april 2016
prince mohammed bill salman
the strongest man in the kingdom
announced an ambitious reform plan
known as saudi vision 2030. the goal of
this reform plan is
nothing less than to transform the
country's economy
completely say look this is a good plan
we need to diversify away because
of necessity otherwise the country will
have far more difficulties in the years
to come the plan aims to achieve
total independence from oil by 2020 and
become one of the most globally
competitive economies by 2030.
the first step of this starts by
privatizing aramco
this is one of the world's largest
companies which controls
10 percent of global oil production the
company's estimated value is
five times that of apple with all the
money from that privatization addition
of foreign reserves
other privatizations of public companies
and its real estate saudi arabia wants
to generate a sovereign wealth fund
of two trillion dollars
this will allow them to get a more
predictable and stable income than they
are currently getting from oil they also
want to eliminate many of the subsidies
that are currently threatening their
economy and invest in new sectors like
mining finance and importantly the
military industry
uber is getting a three and a half
billion dollar investment from
saudi arabia's public investment fund
new taxes are also going to be
introduced as another method of earning
for the government
the prince also wants to change the
higher educational system which is
currently closer to the quran
and develop it to meet modern market
requirements but
the big question has to be is saudi
arabia
going to succeed it is no easy task for
a country to quickly become an
industrial power
and it is unlikely that tourists are
going to be drawn to a country which
sees people
regularly stoned for homosexuality or
adultery
however all of that said saudi arabia's
success will benefit the world no matter
how repulsive we personally find their
policies
70 percent of the saudi population is
under 30 years old and over the next 10
years
they're going to require 2 million jobs
we all know that when
frustration unemployment and religious
fundamentalism add up
the consequences can be truly dangerous
to all
dubai has proved that moderation and
capitalism can lead to changes in
fundamentalist regimes
we can only hope that saudi arabia can
successfully follow the example that has
been set
by dubai but that is our opinion here at
visualpolitik we want to know what you
think do you think saudi arabia will
succeed do you think it will
successfully follow the example that has
been set
by dubai do you think that capitalism
can encourage moderation
in countries like saudi arabia do let us
know your opinion in the comments below
we're looking forward to reading them
and if you did like this video why don't
you give it a thumbs up
below it really helps us out and don't
forget to subscribe we put out brand new
videos just like this
every monday and every thursday so if
you subscribe
you won't miss any of those and i'll see
you next time